>> Well, good afternoon, everyone.
And welcome to another exciting Authors at
Google Talk.
Today, we're very honored to host Viktor Mayer-Schonberger.
He's the Associate Professor of Public Policy
and the Director of Information and Innovation
on Policy at the Research Centre at the National
University of Singapore.
He's also a faculty affiliate at the Belfer
Center of Science and International Affairs
at Harvard University.
And his love of the tech world dates way back.
Even in the early 80's, he led one of the
first companies to work on antivirus protocols.
And he developed Virus Utilities, which became
one of the bestselling Austrian software product
of that time.
And, as you know, the Internet has developed
and keeps acquiring data by the gigabyte every
day, just like a giant, virtual addict.
Much of the work we do here at Google, of
course, is to make sense of all the mass,
and bring order to the chaos, and also to
place it in the context of history.
As an impulsive saver myself, I'm a huge fan
of Gmail's archive, you know, uploading my
files to the picasa as a permanent storage.
And, you know, having all my blog posts saved
in Google Reader.
But, what does that all mean for the future?
Like, how are folks from the future going
to make sense of it, and how am I going to
make sense of it later on?
Do we really need everything?
In this case, Viktor's book paints the picture.
The book is called "Delete: The virtue of
forgetting."
Do we really need tools that automatically
capture everything?
For those of you who may have been here for
our previous talk a few weeks ago, we hosted
Gordon Bell and Jim Gemmell, who are two researchers
a little bit at the opposite end of this spectrum.
They literally record everything that happens
to them at 24 hours a day.
But, is that really necessary, and how will
future researchers and lawyers use our corpus
of information?
So Viktor will help us answer those questions.
Towards the end of the talk, we will have
time for a Question and Answer session.
So we'll have a mic available.
And, without further ado, please join me in
welcoming Viktor.
Thank you very much.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.
This is an interesting experience for me to
talk about forgetting at Google.
So, I have not a real presentation in the
"presentation" sense, and it's also not like
a bookreading.
It's more like a meditation -- a meditation
of the importance of forgetting and remembering.
We okay with the audio and everything?
Stacy Snyder wanted to be a teacher.
By spring of 2006, she had completed her coursework,
and she was looking forward to her teacher's
certificate.
Then, from one day to the next, her dream
was over.
She was summoned to the administration of
the university, and told that she would not
receive her certificate.
She would not be a teacher, she was told,
although she had the credits, passed the exams,
completed the practical training.
She would not be given her certificate, because
her behavior was unbecoming of a teacher.
Her behavior? A photograph, showing her with
a cap and a cup, captioned, "Drunken Pirate."
Stacy Snyder had put this photograph on her
MySpace page for her friends to see and perhaps
to chuckle.
But the university administration found the
photo, and found the photo to induce minors
to consume alcohol, and therefore, to be unbecoming
of a future teacher.
When Stacy was confronted by the university
administration, she considered taking the
photo offline, but it was too late.
Her photo had been indexed by search engines
like yours and archived by web crawlers.
As much as Stacy wanted the photo to be forgotten,
the Internet wouldn't permit that. Remembering
instead of forgetting.
Remembering. Forgetting.
In 2001, Andrew Feldmar, a Canadian psychotherapist
living in Vancouver, wrote an academic article
in a journal.
In the article, he mentioned that in the 60's
he had taken LSD.
In the summer of 2006, like many times before,
Andrew Feldmar wanted to cross into the United
States to pick up a friend from Seattle International
Airport.
The immigration officer Googled "Feldmar,"
and discovered the academic article from 2001.
Because Andrew Feldmar had failed to disclose
to the administration office -- although he
had never denied it -- that he had taken drugs
40 years earlier, he was barred from entering
the United States forever.
Remembering instead of forgetting.
Of course, you may say, "Now, Stacy's and
Andrew's cases are tragic, but at least, in
part, because of their own fault.
Had they not put the information online, Stacy
would now be a teacher and Andrew could still
drive into the United States.
Everybody has to decide for herself or for
himself what to make available online."
To paraphrase [indistinct], "What once has
been put on the web is no longer forgotten."
Really?
Do we really know every time information about
us is being collected, stored, and made accessible?
Do you know that the information, for example,
you put on your change-of-address-card in
your local post office when you move does
not go to the post office?
It goes directly to the Direct Marketing Association.
Do you know that most states in the United
States have no policy to delete DNA information
that has been collected from you when you
were a witness or a victim of a crime?
Instead of deleting that DNA information once
the case has been closed, law enforcement
in this country will run criminal searches
against you, against your DNA information,
for decades to come.
You're an automatic suspect.
Remembering. Forgetting.
For millennia, for us humans, forgetting has
been easy.
It's built into us.
Biologically, we forget most of what we experience
every day: Our feelings, our thoughts.
Remembering is the hard part.
Since the beginning of time, therefore, we
humans have tried to overcome biological forgetting
and to hold to memories that are precious.
For thousands of years, we have tried -- like
this Navaho in this picture -- to pass on
our memories to our children in the hope that
they may too be thus able to remember.
This is how the great epics of the world came
into being thousands of years ago.
But human memory, as we know, is not fixed.
It changes as we reconstruct continuously
our past.
Depending on it may not be sufficient, especially
when we want to capture something precisely,
or for a long period of time.
Painting, as humans found out, is one way
of encapsulating a visual impression to create
an external, more precise, and more-lasting
memory, like this beautiful cave painting
from the caves of Alta Mira.
Script, originally developed -- whether you
believe it -- by accountants, searching for
a precise method of remembering, has for millennia
remained humanity's preferred external memory.
Language, painting, script provided us with
the capacity to remember through generations
and across time.
But these tools have not altered a fundamental
fact that, for us human beings, forgetting
is easy, and remembering is hard, time consuming,
and costly.
The book did not change this either.
Neither did the phonograph or film.
Remembering remained expensive for most human
beings, and was thus chosen carefully.
Forgetting was the default; remembering, the
exception.
This enabled us to deal with time.
Through our physiological capacity to forget,
we rid ourselves of excess memory.
What has long been past fades in our mind.
Thus, we pay tribute to time and to depreciate
what is no longer important -- what is no
longer relevant to our present.
But, because forgetting is biological, we
humans never had to develop a cognitive capacity
to deliberately forget.
That is, to depreciate memories and to make
them fade.
Today, this is different.
You guys remember, Yahoo remembers, Amazon
remembers, the Internet Archive remembers.
Flight reservation systems remember.
Yes, you didn't know that.
If you look for a flight, never book it, still
remembers it six months with your name,
of course.
From biological forgetting, we have moved
to permanent remembering.
You know, as much as I do, how this came apart.
Four elements: Digitization, the increase
in storage capacity to track, Moore's Law,
the increase of IC density, easy retrieval,
and fast global infrastructures.
Taken together, this has led to remembering
becoming the default, and forgetting, the
exception.
To the extent that should be absolute reason
for celebration.
After all, haven't we humans tried for thousands
of years to overcome the straightjacket of
biological forgetting and failing human memories?
And, in fact, our vast digital memories offer
numerous benefits, from improved accuracy
to increased efficiency to, ultimately, the
promise to help us overcome human mortality.
But by the same token, I believe that forgetting
has consequences, or the undoing of forgetting
has consequences far beyond the narrow confines
of efficiency.
Two words characterize what I believe is truly
at stake: Power and Time.
Power is a relative and relational term.
As information privacy scholars have long
argued, power over information may translate
into power over the person the information
pertains or relates to.
If others not only have information about
us, but the capacity to keep such information
in digital storage, accessible long after
we ourselves have forgotten about it, this
informational power increases, and has the
potential to influence how we transact and
interact.
But power is not only diactic.
Jeremy Benton in the 19th century.
Jeremy Benton proposed the panopticon.
The panopticon is the concept of a prison
in which the prison guards can watch the prisoners
without the prisoners knowing when they're
being watched.
The aim is behavioral compliance through the
threat of invisible surveillance.
Oscar Gandian Utters have suggested that the
Internet may help create a sense of a global
panopticon in which everybody has to assume
that she's been watched all the time.
Such a panopticon may lead people to self-censor,
fearing that their utterances could be misconstrued
by any one of the hundreds of millions of
people in thousands of jurisdictions around
the world.
A few years back, the American CEO of the
Bavarian of the German subsidiary of CompuServe
in Munich, Bavaria, was apprehended and charged
with criminal misconduct by the Bavarian authorities
for a UseNet posting placed in the United
States, but held temporarily on a CompuServe
server in the local office.
The economists at that time wrote, "If Bavaria
wrinkles its nose, must the world catch a
cold?"
That is what the global panopticon can do.
But today, I believe we may face more than
just a global panopticon.
Because of comprehensive digital memory, we
have to assume that what we do or say online
is not only being witnessed today, but will
remain accessible for years, perhaps decades
to come.
This creates a temporal panopticon, in which
we may self-censor, not because we may be
afraid how others may interpret or words and
deeds today, but how people and institutions
in the future might view them.
My second concern is Time, or more precisely,
how we humans deal with time.
As I mentioned, forgetting is biological.
So we humans did never have to develop conscious
mechanisms to put different temporally-apart
pieces of memory in a temporal perspective.
So, consider as an illustration the following
hypothetical.
Jane and John are old friends.
Although they live in different cities now,
they try to catch up at least once a year.
One day, Jane receives an e-mail from John
telling her that he's coming to town and wants
to meet.
Jane is excited.
She hasn't seen him for about a year, and
she wants to reply immediately, suggesting
a nice place to meet.
To facilitate that, and to remind her where
the last time when John was in town they met,
she queries her e-mail box folder.
Up pop dozens of e-mail messages she has received
from John over the years.
She's quickly browsing through them to find
the right one, but then her eye catches one,
a ten-year-old e-mail with a strange subject
line.
Intrigued, she starts to scan the text, and
she begins to read.
Surprised, perhaps even shocked, she reads
in the e-mail about how John deceived her
And she is revisiting an angry exchange between
them.
Slowly, events and feelings triggered by this
very concrete, external stimulus come to her
mind -- her sense of betrayal, deception.
She reads on about how, over the following
months, apparently John and her must have
reconciled.
Although, exactly how and why, the e-mails
don't tell.
But, at the forefront of her mind at that
moment is that John, her good friend John,
deceived her.
And suddenly, she is not so sure anymore whether
she wants to meet John, or whether she's looking
forward to seeing him.
As much as her analytic mind wants to disregard
the revived memory, the angry words she read
triggered her remembering.
There, the external memory that help us remember
things that we thought we forget, but in certain
circumstances, they may also cloud our ability
to evaluate and to decide.
Put in more abstract terms, as cognitive psychologists
remind us, for us humans, it is difficult
to realize time as a dimension of change.
When we are confronted with two pieces of
memory, temporally apart, it's cognitively
difficult for us to evaluate them with time
in mind, and not to be captured by the memory
confronting us coming back to us.
We can try, but frequently, the act of remembering
something a long time ago perhaps facilitated
by the external stimulus we receive, will
bring it back into our mind with a certain
freshness and intensity, or not at all.
That may trigger incorrect decision making.
Now, that's not something new.
In the analog times, the dangers were there
too, but they were limited.
Our biological forgetting then obscured our
cognitive difficulty with time, but what when
we are not permitted to forget?
We know a little bit about the consequences
of this with studies of less than a handful
of people who have biological difficulties
to forget.
This is AJ, a woman who has difficulties forgetting.
Ask her about a particular day, she's able
to tell you she woke up, who called, what
was on television, 30 years ago.
AJ has difficulties forgetting, but to her,
she says in many instances, it's not a blessing.
It's a curse.
She is haunted at times by her past so much,
in fact, that it limits her ability to act
and decide in the present.
As Argentinian short story writer, Jorges
Borges, said, "Perfect memory pushes humans
to get lost in detail with no ability to generalize,
to abstract, and to evolve
They lose," Borges writes, "what truly makes
us human."
Tethered to an ever more detailed past, rather
than living and acting in the present.
This is the fate we may face with comprehensive
digital memory.
Through perfect digital memory, we also may
deny each other the capacity to change over
time, to evolve, and to grow.
Without forgetting, it is hard for us to forgive.
And so, with comprehensive digital remembering,
we may turn into an unforgiving society.
But, there is another wrinkle to the story.
What if? What if frustrated with the shortcomings
of our human biological memory, we begin to
disregard our own recollections of our own
past and depend on digital memory instead?
Does that give those that control digital
memory the power to change history?
These are some of the threats of shifting
the defaults from forgetting to remembering.
So, what to do?
So far, we have come up with a couple of possible
responses to deal with digital memory and
digital remembering.
First is, the idea of privacy rights.
The idea, the underlying concept, is intriguingly
simple.
By giving each individual the right to informational
privacy, we empower the people themselves
to fight for their rights.
Therefore, enforcement of the rights, enforcement
of digital forgetting, is both decentralized
and delegated.
It sounds great, but it comes with a number
of inherent weaknesses.
First, in the U.S., the enactment of informational
privacy rights is politically not feasible,
at least not in the current political climate.
But, even if it were, I have my doubts about
its effectiveness.
Because the Europeans have enacted strong
information privacy rights for decades, but
people have not used them.
Whatever additional incentives frustrated
lawmakers offered the public: no-fault compensation,
attorney fees, shifting the burden of proof,
nothing could change the bitter reality that
individuals do not seem to want to enforce
their information privacy rights.
At least not in courts.
So maybe, information ecology norms could
help.
These norms are the conscious regulatory restriction
of what personal information can be stored
and for how long.
Such norms necessitate government action,
because they have to be passed through Parliament,
and compliance enforcement may therefore be
costly.
They do have two advantages over privacy rights.
They do not require individuals to have to
go to court for enforcement, and they protect
against an unforeseen future.
An unforeseen future.
Well, here is an interesting case to consider.
Consider the Dutch Citizen Register.
Put in place in the 1930's for a perfectly
good reason: Do no evil.
To ensure the administration of social security,
the register included information about ethnicity
and religion.
Once the Nazis had occupied the Netherlands,
they raided the register, repurposing the
information in it to identify Dutch Jews,
and to send them to concentration camps.
As a result, proportionally-speaking, more
Dutch Jews were murdered at the hands of the
Nazis than those of from France, Poland, or
Germany.
Even Jewish refugees in the Netherlands fared
better, because they were not included in
the Dutch Citizen Register.
It is a horrific lesson.
As we cannot see the future, and thus, how
personal information about us is being used,
it may be better to store less than more.
This is the essence of information ecology
norms.
Unfortunately, since nine eleven, we have
seen a backlash here, together with a wave
of information retention norms.
In addition to the pervasive rhetoric of fear
and security, information ecology norms also
go against another emerging dogma in our society,
that of transparency.
Transparency has become our preferred, perhaps
only, mechanism for ensuring good governance,
both in the public and the private sector,
requiring information retention, and thus
limiting the political chances for an expansion
of information ecology norms.
So, are there any alternative responses that
we could use, perhaps, to augment our existing
responses with some alternative ideas?
Some have argued for digital abstinence, for
staying away from the technical tools that
have enabled digital remembering.
Not sharing everything on Facebook, as President
Obama reminded us a few weeks back.
Certainly reduce the threat of digital remembering.
But is it realistic?
With over six hundred plus million registered
users worldwide on social networking sites,
two out of three young Americans, by the end
of 2007, uploaded and shared information about
themselves with others.
Is it realistic?
Another option, ostensibly the opposite of
digital abstinence, is the idea of full contextualization,
or to store digitally as much information
as possible.
That might sound strange, but here's the argument.
Perhaps the problem with digital memory is
that it does not capture enough.
That is, enough of an event to let us relive
it accurately enough later on.
If we could only store everything related
to it, including its context, we could avoid
the negative side effects of memory -- of
digital memory.
In essence, full contextualization could help
us regain our ability to think in time, and
at the same time, it would equalize information
imbalances.
At its core, this is Brin's proposal for a
transparent society.
But will full contextualization ever be technically
feasible?
You heard Gordon Bell talk about his life-blogging.
He is still not capturing everything.
And if it is, would it actually address the
challenge of digital remembering?
Do we really have the time to relive our past
again and again, only to grasp what experiences
are no longer relevant for us today?
Perhaps.
Perhaps we need to look at another alternative,
namely, cognitive adjustment.
Cognitive adjustment is the hope that, over
time, we'll learn to devalue older information,
and to live in a world of the omnipresent
past.
Not society has to change its laws, but the
way our individual processes of information
evaluation, and decision making work.
That to me sounds right.
And that would solve our problem.
I like this approach.
But unfortunately, cognitive psychologists
are extremely skeptical of our human ability
to force onto us a change in how we evaluate
and process distant memory that we suddenly
recall through the external stimulus of digital
storage.
They suggest that it may take us humans a
very long time to change the way we assess
the information around us, to modify what
we've been doing for ages.
And if we could, what would be the appropriate
mechanism to affect such change.
I hope cognitive adjustment is working, but
I don't want to hold my breath.
So, perhaps, you guys can help here.
Perhaps you guys can provide us with visual
and contextual cues in how search results
are being presented to users, to individuals,
so that older and less-relevant information
can be radically reduced in importance.
A different idea is not to change humans,
but to change technology.
Lawrence Lecig and others had suggested to
use technology to change human behavior.
The suggestion is to create quasi-property
rights in personal information.
Think of personal information copyright.
Oh gosh, copyright -- another conundrum -- and
build that into our technology, so that technology
can ensure that only those can process my
personal information who I have permitted
to do so.
In short, the suggestion is to create a global
digital rights management system to protect
privacy.
But do we really need to create a global technology
infrastructure that watches every of our moves
to ensure that nobody abuses somebody else's
personal information?
Wouldn't we thereby not create a perfect surveillance
system to ensure privacy?
In order for privacy therein to work, we would
have to embed into the infrastructure privacy
very deeply, and I have not seen an engineering
solution that does that.
So here we are.
I presented six possible approaches to you
to deal with the challenges posed by digital
remembering.
Privacy Rights and Information Ecology.
Employ legal norms to address the challenge.
Digital Abstinence and Cognitive Adjustment.
Hope that this could be achieved on an individual
level and privacy DRM and full contextualization
mainly rest on achieving a technical breakthrough.
The three on the left-hand-side: Digital Abstinence,
Privacy Rights, and Privacy DRM, mainly target
the power challenge of digital remembering.
The three of them on the right aim at addressing
the time challenge.
None of these, as you have discovered, offers
us a silver bullet, although all help in their
very unique way to counter the challenge ahead.
Hence, we may need to mix and combine them,
and perhaps, even add something else.
So, something else?
If you have followed me so far, I've probably
achieved 95 percent of what I wanted to achieve,
but here's the five percent that are the controversial
part.
So I advocate for a revival of forgetting.
That is, to establish mechanisms that ease
the forgetting in the digital age and that
make remembering just a tiny bit more strenuous,
not by much.
I don't want to overly burden remembering,
but just enough to shift the incentives of
forgetting and remembering back to what we
humans are used to.
One version of this could be called "expiration
dates for information."
It would imply that whenever we want to store
information, we are prompted to enter a date
until which we want that information to be
stored.
Once the date has been reached, the information
has been purged.
Of course, we can choose expiration dates
at will and can change it at any time.
Please understand.
The core of my proposal is not the automatic
deletion of information or the technical infrastructure
to create compliance.
The core of my proposal is that, by prompting
for expiration dates, this prompt will remind
us time and again that most information is
not timeless, but linked to a specific context
and situation -- that it loses its value as
time passes.
Expiration dates would offer a meaningful
way of linking digital memory with time, and
thereby implementing a temporal dimension
into it.
It is cognitive reflection of the longevity
of information lifespan, and the importance
of forgetting that I'm after on an individual,
as well as a societal, level.
I want us to have a meaningful choice again
of what to forget and what to remember, rather
than to have to accept the implicit bias of
digital remembering.
I'm not suggesting that expiration dates offer
perfection, only the chance to reflect and
to choose.
Now, of course, this is where -- for the lawyers
and the engineers -- the fun starts.
How are expiration dates negotiated in diactic
settings?
How are they maintained?
How is compliance ensured once they have been
set?
And I talk more about that in the book.
Moreover, much of the mass acceptance, if
ever, will depend on user experience.
How straight forward is it to select an expiration
date?
Can developers, like you, help by offering
suitable presets based on information type
and context?
What are the tools available to users to change
expiration date post fact?
There is no one-size-fits-all expiration date
system, but rather a whole spectrum of instantiation
of expiration dates imaginable, with some
based mainly on market pressure to assure
compliance, and others depending on more laws
or technical measures.
Make no mistake, while helpful as an illustration,
expiration dates come with a bag of weaknesses
of their own.
They're no silver bullet.
They're not designed to solve the informational
privacy challenges beyond digital remembering.
Perhaps the most troubling, from my perspective,
is that expiration dates are still very binary,
while human forgetting is much more gradual.
Perhaps, we can develop systems, you can develop
systems of digital forgettings that are more
gradual as well.
Provide a kind of digital rusting if you want,
and not as dynamically-adapted expiration
dates as our individual preferences evolve.
It all sounds like a tall order, but hey.
The time challenge outlined earlier, but of
course, not the power challenge, can be addressed
at least to an extent, by ensuring older and
perhaps less-relevant information takes a
little bit longer to be retrieved, so that
we don't stumble over it, like Jane did, and
thus risk clouding our decision-making in
the present.
Remembering, putting photos in a shoe box
in the attic.
You still have them, and if you want to spend
the time to go up in the attic, you can still
find them there, although some of them may
have faded slightly over the years.
But retrieving them takes a little bit of
effort, and thereby, it makes forgetting the
default and remembering the exception.
That little bit of extra effort is what helps
us stay focused on the present and our present
challenges.
And if you can help us individually and as
a society to do that, you not only enjoy,
perhaps a competitive advantage, but you may
do us all a real favor.
So there are many variants of digital forgetting,
but whatever version one can come up with,
I do foresee two features common to all.
The first is, changing the default from remembering
back to forgetting.
Forgetting can be slow, gradual, or reconsidered.
But, it must empower users to set it as they
desire, and it must be made the default and
remembering the exception.
The second core feature is the digital forgetting
keeps reminding us of the temporal nature
of information, that it is not timeless, but
linked to specific context, and thus loses
its usefulness as time progresses.
And that it offers us a meaningful mechanism
to link temporal dimension with information
we commit to digital storage.
A revival of digital forgetting, I believe,
if used in combination with some of the other
approaches, could significantly strengthen
the effectiveness of our overall societal
response to the challenge of Power and Time
that we face.
Forgetting. Remembering.
Since the beginning of time, forgetting has
been easy for us, and remembering hard.
In the digital age, the relationship has become
reversed.
Today, digital remembering is the default,
and it is forgetting that is often forgotten.
I ask you -- I ask you to help bring back
-- and give back -- to forgetting, the role
it deserves.
Let us remember to forget.
Thanks.
>> [applause]
>> Sure.
>> One thing with forgetting is that it strikes
me as permanent.
If you forget something, you can't bring it
back.
At the same time, if you save it, you can
always delete it.
So how does that work with defaults if you
are deleting things you regret?
>> Okay.
So the question was, If you delete something,
it's gone forever.
But if you save something, you can then later
delete it.
And so the implicit is, or assumption is,
wouldn't it be better to just save it, and
you can always delete it?
Whereas, if you have deleted it, you can't
go back.
Now, of course, that kind of obscures what's
at stake.
If you look at the time challenge, just by
saving it, I'm potentially already confusing
myself if I have fast retrieval, because it's
coming back.
And it's like Jane, or like the case of Jane,
may cloud my decision-making.
So in that sense, saving in the fear that
I might need it in the future, immediately
has consequence in the present, because it
is accessible to me.
A more benign version of what you suggested
is the shoe box version, and that is to not
throw stuff away, but to actually put it in
the shoe box and up in the attic, or some
have told me they've saved their e-mails,
but put it in a separate folder and put it
in a backup drive.
So if they absolutely have to go back, and
if it's worth their time and effort to do
that, they can do it, but it doesn't necessarily
pop up when they search through their mailbox
folder immediately.
That's a benign version and that might help
address some of the time challenge.
What it doesn't address is the power challenge.
It does nothing to help protect us from an
unforeseen future.
If the Dutch Jews had done what you just said,
they would still be prosecuted.
They would still be sent to the concentration
camps.
So, in that sense, the power challenge remains
unaddressed.
>> [inaudible]
>> Right. Sure.
So the question was, Isn't there a lot of
information from the past that is incredibly
valuable or could be incredibly valuable,
and by deleting it or by forgetting it faster
than preserving it, we would actually rid
ourself of that potential value?
Is that an accurate statement?
Yeah, that's -- I don't want to deny that.
Now, two parts of my answer here.
Part Number One.
A lot of medical information, supposedly buried
in the archives of the scientific community
or so, are of dubious value.
Because a lot of the technology that was available
ten, twenty, thirty, forty, years ago to the
medical community was comparatively primitive
to our current technology.
And so we wouldn't do certain things the way
it was done.
We wouldn't use certain treatments the way
they were.
So the amount of knowledge that can be mined
from these information treasures is probably
somewhat more limited than we might hope.
The only real discipline that I think would
really suffer if we stop remembering completely
or largely would be historians, who now can
use digital records and have much more of
that available.
That brings me to the second part of my answer
and that is, I don't want to enforce or to
force us to forget.
My idea is not to compelling us to forget.
My idea is to compel us to choose.
And I want to give choice back to us individuals
to choose.
And that might actually be beneficial both
for the individual as well as for those who
then use the information later on, because
the quality of the information might be superior,
might improve.
Because, as an individual, I have an interest
in low-quality information that is not relevant
anymore to be purged, and information that
is relevant to my current condition not to
be purged, but to be remembered.
So, I really want to give back choice, and
choice on a individual as well as a societal
level.
So, if I want to keep my photographs, if you
want to keep your blog posts for the next
five hundred years, just set the expiration
date to the first of January 2500, and you'll
be fine.
And by the way, the 31st of December 2499,
you just want to keep it longer, you should
be able to go back and just change the expiration
date and add another three hundred or five
hundred years to it.
That's all fine with me.
That's perfectly fine.
As long as you have that choice.
And similarly, as a society, I think we should
have that choice.
We should have that choice as a society to
decide whether a drunk driver's citation 15
years ago is still relevant today, or not.
Think about that for a moment, what it does
in terms of the legal retention compliance
issues.
If you are in a human resource department
of a large organization like Google, and you
have a job applicant, and you Google the job
applicant, and you find out something in the
distant past like 15 years ago in the past
of that job applicant.
Now, you know it.
So you have that information.
If something happens, link to that piece of
information, you as a human resource department
are going to be liable.
So, you cannot not act on it.
Now, you need to act on it.
Even though it might be completely irrelevant,
and guess what, given the precautionary principle
that most human resource departments heed,
that person is not going to get hired, or
is much less likely getting hired.
Despite the fact that it has no relevance,
this past fact has no relevance to the present
situation of the person.
Just caution.
Pure liability-reducing, risk-reducing caution.
And so, if we had digital forgetting built
into it of those irrelevant information pieces
of our past, we could address this kind of
situation.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate, particularly, let me add one
thing.
I know you're in the business of conserving
and retaining information, and I really appreciate
you listening in to the dissident.
Thank you.
>> [clapping]